joseph joestar is a very proud man who
holds his subscription to the new world
review amongst his greatest achievements
in life primarily because it does grant
him regular jojo content straight into
his youtube feed
however when joseph hears that someone
is not subscribed to the new world
review
then he has a tendency to make this face
so please
subscribe this face is weird i don't
like it and i need it to stop
hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we are going to begin
what will in theory be potentially an
incredibly long journey as we attempt to
catalog the various stands in jojo's
bizarre adventure in a new series
titled the stand encyclopedia however
before we can launch into individual
stand examination we first need to
actually define stands themselves
because these existences take on a wide
variety
of forms and if i was to start any entry
by saying something like well this stand
is a close range artificial humanoid
well what meaning does that have without
defining all of that business first so
today we are here to lay the groundwork
and we're going to begin with a very
simple question
what is a stand well essentially a stand
is a culmination of life energy that
manifests itself into a particular form
taking great inspiration from the users
fighting spirit psyche
intellectual curiosity or they can even
form themselves in direct response to a
particular need now obviously that's a
very vague definition and purposely so
because stands can establish themselves
in a limitless array of outcomes
although for the most part they do tend
to share a set of common features that
does allow us to define them now
generally a user is bound to their stand
meaning that if something damages the
stand then the user themselves incurs
damage and in the large majority of
cases should a stand user die then the
stand itself will disappear
a large majority of cases not all and as
for where stands come from in the first
place the sad fact is at least in the
first jojo universe you must be born
with a stand or the potential to
manifest one later in life which would
occur through profound mental strength
with that said there is also a quick and
dirty way to do it which is by being
pierced with an arrow made from an
otherworldly metal and if the person
being pierced was born with stand
potential then it will be unlocked and
if not then they will
they'll die pretty big gamble
interestingly enough having a stand
unlocked in this way
also results in a person's descendants
being able to manifest their stance if
they possess the potential which is one
of the primary catalyzing features of
jojo's bizarre adventure as we know it
meanwhile in the alternate universe
continuity of jojo these arrows
obviously don't exist and the primary
method by which stand development seems
to occur is via a mysterious shenanigan
regarding the saints corpse now as for
what kind of stance can emerge let's get
into the convoluted classification
system
which begins by being able to divide
stands into three broad types each of
which are going to have a slew of
subtypings but the original three
are ability types form types and special
types and very notably these typings are
not exclusive at any given stand will
often be distinguished by being
classified into at least two of those
broad types but this will make much more
sense as we get into it
starting with the ability typing
classification and this sector tends to
focus on allotting a stand based on the
range of its abilities so for example a
common subcategory we have here would be
a close range power type which are
generally your standard punch ghosts who
can't be more than a few meters away
from their user at any given time or i
guess they can but they become much less
effective in addition to this their
particular abilities might
be able to be used at range but they
themselves do need to stick quite close
by and a classic example of this would
be star platinum which has an effective
range of two meters from joturo and we
also have the long distance operation
types which
are stands able to operate at great
range away from their users
and a simple example of this would be
hierophant green wielded by kakyoin
what's more important to note here
though is that being a long distance
operation type
does not automatically mean that the
stan's ability is long distance
it may still be a very close range power
it can just be performed far far away
from the stan's user now these first two
sub classifications are still types of
stands that remain under the control of
their users but there are ability types
that operate on their own known as
automatic stands
which act as i said on their own under a
very simple set of commands
but they also have the distinction of
being able to act at incredible
distances away from the user however
they
are very very basic and once you figure
out effectively the one thing that the
stand is basing its decisions on then
they are usually quite easily defeated
for example killer queen sheer heart
attack ability is a far distance
autopilot type it chooses its target
based on who or whatever has the highest
temperature and very interestingly
within the world of automatic stance are
the posthumous types which either
activate or endure after their user's
death albeit with the same basic
programming as automatic stance and
notorious big from part 5 would be a
fantastic illustration of this which
attacks what it detects as the fastest
moving object within its range
and finally for ability types we also
have range irrelevant stands which
generally comprise the most terrifying
and powerful stance within the series
however the base definition of this
class are stands with abilities where
range is well like it says
irrelevant so anything that manipulates
time would be plonkier including the
world king crimson and mandam however
these stands are kind of crazy
because many of their abilities have the
potential to affect the entirety of
existence as we know it and yes i am
looking at you
made in heaven but casting ability types
aside we can also be much more
superficial and identify stands
according to their form type which
comprises five subcategories
and first up we have the common natural
humanoid stands which are exactly as it
sounds
stands which take on an organic
humanistic appearance although they
obviously don't have to mirror humanity
perfectly because things like avdol's
magician's red falls into this category
despite the fact that it does have the
head of a birdie but for a more classic
example we could turn to josuke's crazy
diamond which is effectively just a big
old dude bra
with some fairly insane powers of its
own then we move to artificial humanoid
stands which are almost the same thing
except they achieve a humanist
appearance through some sort of less
than organic construction like silver
chariot which looks like a medieval
robot or one of the stands that creeps
me out the most f13 which is cobbled
together with various non-organic matter
they would both be artificial humanoid
stands and to keep the sheer excitement
of knowledge we have going we also have
natural non-humanoid stands which i feel
like you may get the gist of by now they
are anything that takes on construction
through organic matter but does not
resemble a human appearance
and the first one of those that always
comes to mind to me is straight cat who
is a delightful cat
plant and of course to contrast that we
also have artificial non-humanoid stands
which you probably get yeah non-human
forms crafted from artificial materials
like bastet was you know
literally a powerpoint or much more
interestingly in the realm of part 8 we
have the very cool existence known as
paper moon king
but quite possibly the most exciting
subcategory of the form types are the
phenomenon stands
which basically means anything that does
not fit into the previous four
explored categories and to be clear what
that means is that it cannot manifest as
a humanoid form and it cannot be
constructed from natural or artificial
materials
so what does that leave us with well
phenomenon stands often exhibit
themselves as supernatural occurrences
or an ability granted to the user
directly say for example aktung baby
wielded by shizuka joestar which allows
her to turn herself and a select radius
around her invisible although the power
doesn't need to affect the user it can
also be applied to targets and victims
such as part 7 scary monsters which
allowed its user to infect living beings
with a virus that inevitably turned them
into dinosaurs which is it's pretty fun
for more fun though we're now going to
dive into the third broad classification
being special types and i have to note
right at the beginning
this is not an officially recognized
category in the series but more of a
framework that fans have developed over
time
spotting certain trends and i for one do
very much appreciate its existence so we
are going to dive into it here but
firstly and most boringly we have
bound stands which as the name implies
are directly tied to some form of
material or object and which also goes
on to mean that regular humans can often
see their effects actually
and the very first example of this we
saw in the series was strength which was
bound to a ship and controlled by an
orangutan because
that's jojo and it allowed said
orangutan to manipulate the ship as he
saw fit the more fun example though
would probably be superfly which was
bound to a transmission tower in mario
and had the ability to trap people
within it as well as reflect all damage
dealt to it
so something of an invincible
transmission tower moving on within the
special type we also have colony stands
which are made up of multiple conjured
beings which can range from small
handfuls like meister sex pistols or a
terrifying army of 60 patchwork soldiers
as seen in nijimora's bad company and
the main advantage of this
brand of stand is rapidly increased
utility and significantly less damage
taken
if part of your stand was to be wounded
plus if not acted one quickly these
small but powerful beings can very
swiftly overwhelm most opponents
keeping mr sex pistols in mind though
another special type is that of a
sentient stand which can obviously be
seen here as each of miesta's pistols
have their own personality
going on to interact with each other
mister and even other stand users
and in some cases sentient stands have
become exceptionally important
characters in their own right such as
foo fighters from part six who is
basically a sentient colony of plankton
that operate via a hive mind and can
infiltrate and control the bodies of
others which has led to the stone ocean
classic character foo fighters who was
aptly named directly after the stand
in addition to this the special type can
also comprise shared stands which allow
a stan to have multiple users at once or
over time an example of the latter would
be anubis from stardust crusaders who
practice the art of user hopping and fun
fact anubis would also be classified as
a sentient stand as well
and i suppose you could also call king
crimson a shared stand to some degree
as it was used by both diavolo and
doppio not really so much what we're
talking about here though finally we
also have evolving stands and these guys
are very very exciting and have resulted
in some of the most ridiculous power
that we have seen in the series but
basically this refers to stands that
have the capacity to evolve for whatever
reason such as koichi's echoes which
took on new forms based on an axe system
and each time they had different powers
and restrictions placed on them
generally becoming far stronger with
each
act but very much their own unique
existences and the stand can also go on
to evolve via that arrow thingy that we
spoke about before which when striking
user a second time can have the effect
of the original stand developing a new
sub ability which occurred in part four
when yoshikaga kira was pierced a second
time
and resulting in killer queen's absurd
bites the dust ability which can place
the targets and thus the world i guess
in a temporal loop so it's not a simple
air cool i have a new fun power to play
with this evolution process does
generally result in some pretty
world-changing stuff
and that can be seen on an even more
profound level when the stand itself is
pierced with the arrow and then it can
evolve into its requiem form which has
been seen in the series in two
incarnations one of which was silver
chariot requiem which had the power to
spot the souls of living organisms but
we also got to see it in the form of
gold experience requiem which had a
strangely esoteric power to revert
anything
back to zero which is far more
terrifying than it sounds so requiem
stands a pretty damn serious business
an evolution of a stand can also occur
through a mysterious process hinted at
but not technically detailed in part six
whereby it involves the fusing of souls
with a stand user and crafting specific
gravitational requirements which yeah i
know
sounds very obscure but it did result in
the insanity that is made in heaven so
yeah in conclusion stand evolution is
madness and that is our three broad
typings and their subcategories
so in theory with this information
equipped we should be able to identify
and classify any stand
and in fact let's just test that out
right now let's take moody blues for
example and now we know that we could
classify that as a close range
artificial humanoid stand oh
don't we all feel smart now one last
thing though all stands in the series
are further dissected through a
parameter system that measures the six
key classes of statistics those being
destructive power
speed range persistence precision and
development potential with each state
being assigned a rank from a to e
and it generally provides us with a nice
solid visual cheat sheet of a stan's
general strength and weaknesses one that
we will apply going forward in this
encyclopedia
although they are quite inconsistent so
just a
warning there and that does pretty much
do it for this prologue to the stand
encyclopedia and i suppose next time we
will be picking up with our first
official entry which is going to be star
platinum
wielded by the one and only joe turokujo
so yeah we'll see how that goes i'm
honestly pretty nervous about this whole
idea because jojo views on this channel
are hard enough to come by as it is but
we're going to give it a go
anyway but what do you guys think please
do let me know down in the comments
below and if you are keen for some more
jojo content then please do go and check
out some of my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel for regular
jojo wonder delivered straight into your
youtube feed but for now this has been
the new world review
and i'll see you next time